casting for a show like cobra kai must
be an exciting process from finding
fresh talent that had a surprising lack
of karate training to bringing back
stars from the original series let's
take a peek inside the dojo at how these
actors came into their roles
number one the perfect student cholo
maraduena landed his role the second his
audition was over so he was miguel diaz
from the start he knew very little about
karate going into the show only having
taken a year of it when he was super
young he also only had three years of
acting experience at the time which he
was still a kid so it's not that
surprising but in hollywood you're
competing with a lot of child stars like
peyton list show low's mom is a huge fan
of the franchise when the script came in
he didn't realize it was the karate kid
because he hadn't seen the movie since
he was like five
and his mom knew immediately what the
show was based on the title once show
low was brought up to speed he knew it
was going to be a big deal it took a
month before he heard about callbacks
and when he went into the room he had to
suppress his inner fanboy when he was
blindsided by billy zabka's presence
after mouser booked her role she came
back in and read with sholo and another
guy for miguel hey i'm miguel my family
and i just moved into 109.
number two
now the designated karate kid tanner
buchanan was in the middle of filming
designated survivor in toronto when he
found out he was casted for robbie keane
tanner did a little bit of karate
training from roughly 10 to 12 years old
but it was really his black belt mom who
introduced him to the karate kid
number 3. mary mouser she should have
been called mary koala mary mouser had
never seen the movies before her
audition do you know what else she
hadn't seen her alarm clock well i okay
i slept through it she slept right
through her audition because she
completely forgot about it her
boyfriend's a huge fan of the series and
he was hyped for mary to maybe become
part of cobra kai when she told him what
the audition she missed was he totally
flipped his lid and was like you've got
to call them back right now
so she had her agent on it and was
brought in the next day but they weren't
auditioning mary's that day so she
didn't get a sense of the competition
she was the only girl who came in for
sam and auditioned across from three
different robbies or miguel's she can't
remember so once she landed the role the
first thing she did was binge all the
movies at her call backs there were
three samantha's and three miguels
tanner buchanan was the only robbie she
saw she was totally intimidated by him
and thought wow he's one of those actor
dudes because he was sitting there with
his headphones in well she's since
learned he was just listening to music
to get into character oh wow that sounds
really interesting
number four pure skill or did they go
easy on him jacob bertrand received an
old version of the script but only found
out in front of the directors he was
given a new script and just 10 minutes
to prepare it yikes three hours later
they called him back to congratulate him
on booking the roll he started taking
karate at eight and had a purple belt
before quitting so he did have a leg up
on a lot of his competition
number five from princess to karate kid
payton list is already a very
experienced actor having worked on
multiple high-profile shows including
the swamp bunkt and jessie she joined
cobra kai mid-season and she picked up
choreography very quickly the night
before she'd been at a friend's movie
premiere so she'd been up super late she
didn't feel great about the audition
since she'd always played sweet girls
she worried nobody would be able to see
her as anything but that
she was a friend of jacob bertrand's
already and her mom told jacob and his
mom about the audition she was really
embarrassed about it but the pair
inquired about the audition which really
got the ball rolling mary mouser heard
through the grapevine about peyton's
audition and wondered how she would pull
off playing someone so cruel i remember
when you were little she was so sweet
how is she gonna be so mean
number six in just one weekend your
whole life is about to change gianni
dicenzo had never left la for work until
he went to film in georgia they were
really down to the wire and about to
film that weekend so he didn't get much
training time like the others well
karate training number seven each actor
required a different kind of convincing
how the show was pitched to billy zabka
and ralph macchio was completely
different the creators of cobra kai
emailed billy zabka and shot idea after
idea after idea at him about having
billy play the anti-hero of the series
he was shocked because he really felt
like when the karate kid with jayden
smith came out that it was all over for
the original series but when the show
was pitched to machio it wasn't flashy
and cool the pitch was about bullying
and machio had a ton of questions they
were pitching the show to him as a
comedy which made him hesitant he wanted
to know where's the comedy what's the
tone where's the miyagi-isms all good
questions
number eight what if your big break is
the audition after you quit courtney
hangaler is a huge karate kid fan she
just had her son and was about to quit
acting when her husband encouraged her
she hang in just a bit longer
at least until they could figure out
their health insurance since they relied
on her acting to cover that the next
week she got the kobrakai audition and
her husband lost his mind she had no
idea how big the project was going to
become
she definitely hardcore judged it too
wondering why not just create something
original instead of capitalizing on the
karate kit franchise
then she read the script and thought
this is gonna be
great number nine
he wanted to be more than a tough guy
martin cove initially signed on to do
the part because the writers really
understood the entire arc of the
character he wanted to come on earlier
but was told no he couldn't come in
earlier than episode 10 of season 1
because they had something special
planned for him in the second season
they just basically gave you
everything you wanted to play as an
actor he usually only plays the tough
guy in the movies so the colors to this
character are what sold him on it saying
it's writing that robert caiman would
have written himself
number ten
he was blown away by the depth of the
character thomas ian griffith wasn't
expecting a call at all but was actually
a fan of the show and had watched it
when it was on youtube but he didn't
think terry really fit into the world
then the rumors started then he got a
call and questioned how the character
would come back griffith was sold on the
backstory of where he was coming from
but also where he was going
number eleven
tired is the theme of these auditions
vanessa rubio submitted a next day self
tape it was the third next day audition
she had to do that day it was perfect
because the character was supposed to be
coming back from work tired she got
feedback right away she sent in another
take and that was that she knew cobra
kai was connected to the karate kid
franchise but didn't realize how big the
show was going to be number 12. she was
just happy to be there elizabeth shue
was already a fan of the show she was
really impressed with how they'd handled
the franchise and was just so excited to
see ralph billy john hayden and josh
they were all so lovely and excited for
her to be on the show that she couldn't
say no
i i cannot believe that you are sensei
maybe 35 years down the line the kids
cast of cobra kai will reunite to give
us a whole new series to fall in love
with if given the opportunity to
audition for the show would you remember
to set your alarm clock whose audition
story did you like the best let us know
in the comments and thanks for watching